remembering a fallen metro police
officer 49-year-old officer Chong Tai
was responding to a domestic disturbance
call on Thursday morning when he was
shot and killed tonight hundreds came
together for Candlelight vigil to honor
him Madison Kimbrough was there and
spoke with those who knew officer Ty
best she joins us live in The Newsroom
with more Madison officer Tai had been
with Metro for over 20 years and by
tonight's turnout it was clear he
impacted so many lives as a mentor on
the force and a coach in the community
I've been overwhelmed and flooded with
the motions
over the past three years I've had the
pleasure of getting to know
tie better than most it was a solemn
night at Sunset Park as friends family
and fellow law enforcement from across
the valley came together in a
candlelight vigil remembering 49 year
old officer trong Tai who died Thursday
morning while on duty responding to a
domestic disturbance call does he like
mentoring some of these young office
his fellow South Central Area command
officers taking the stage to talk about
his presence on the force Myron ham with
the Las Vegas Police Protection
Association arrived early to help out
and shared with us the type of
individual Ty was having worked with him
for over 20 years I don't think Ty ever
met a person he always met a friend and
that's what that's what I I hope people
remember about him the Asian Community
Development Council and the injured
police officers fund hosted the
candlelight vigil as Ty's family who sat
front row shared pictures with the crowd
many flew in from various parts of the
country to attend sharing with us how
important coaching girls volleyball was
to him and what type of man Ty was
outside of the uniform he definitely
influenced so many decisions and my life
in countless ways Tai was that kind of
person that would encourage you to do
the things that you didn't think that
you had it and need to do on your own
and Governor Steve sisilak and Sheriff
Joe Lombardo were also in attendance
tonight sitting near Ty's family the
candlelight vigil lasted for a little
over an hour in The Newsroom Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now
and on Monday the injured police
officer's fund is hosting a fundraiser
to help officer Ty's family it starts at
nine at the Nevada Coin Mart near
Flamingo and Jones law enforcement
merchandise will be on sale all proceeds
will go to the family